>> Pete: WE'RE BACK WITH A FOX
NEWS ALERT.
THE U.S. MILITARY KILLING AN
ISIS-K PLANNER.
WE'RE LEARNING NEW DETAILS.
A U.S. REAPER DRONE FLEW TO
AFGHANISTAN FROM A BASE IN THE
MIDDLE EAST TO KILL THE ISIS-K
PLANNER THAT WAS PLOTTING FUTURE
ATTACKS ON U.S. ATTACKS IN
KABUL.
WE'LL KEEP YOU UPDATED
THROUGHOUT THE HOUR AS THE
SITUATION DEVELOPS.
JOINING ME NOW IS SOUTH CAROLINA
CONGRESSMAN RALPH NORMAN AND
ANDY HARRIS, A FORMER NAVY
RESERVE MEDICAL OFFICER.
CONGRESSMAN HARRIS, YOUR
REACTION OF THE KILLING OF THE
ISIS-K FIGHTER AND WHERE IT PUTS
US 0 IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> IT'S TOO LITTLE TOO LATE,
THIS WON'T RETRIEVE THAT
BUNGLING.
WE HAVE A LOT OF AMERICANS ON
THE GROUND A LOT OF ALLIES.
I DON'T SEE ANYWAY WE CAN BE OUT
BY THE 31st.
>> Pete: YOU THINK HE CAN'T MEET
THE AUGUST 31 DEADLINE.
YOU'RE THINKING GETTING ALL U.S.
TROOPS OUT WON'T HELP.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE STILL HAVE TO GET HUNDREDS IF
NOT THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS OUT.
ALLIES OUT, THOSE THAT HOLD
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISAS AND
FAMILIES AND THEN TROOPS AND
EQUIPMENT.
IT'S A TALL ORDER FOR FOUR DAYS.
>> Pete: SURE IS.
REPRESENTATIVE NORMAN, YOUR TAKE
ON THE STRIKE TONIGHT.
>> LOOK WHAT HAS HAPPENED.
>> 13 AMERICANS DEAD, 20
INJURED.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS A
TOOTHLESS TIGER.
THEY DON'T TRUST HIM.
IF THIS WERE DONALD TRUMP, THE
PURE MIGHT OF THE MILITARY WOULD
BE ON THE TALIBAN.
IT WOULDN'T BE A QUESTION.
BIDEN SET ARBITRARY DATES WITH
NO PLAN IN PLACE.
AS A RESULT, DEAD AMERICANS AND
5,000 LEFT THERE AND ONE DRONE
STRIKE KILLING ONE ISIS MEMBER?
REALLY.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT.
I DON'T SEE ANYTHING COMING OF
IT.
LOOK AS HIS ACTIONS, LOOK AT HIS
RECORD.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE TRYING TO HOLD
BLINKEN AND OTHERS ACCOUNTABLE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO HE HAS TAKEN
ADVICE FROM.
WHATEVER IT IS, IT'S NOT GOOD
>> Pete: THAT'S WHAT WE BOOKED
YOU TO TALK ABOUT.
BOTH OF YOU ARE INTRODUCING
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE BLINKEN.
IF I MAY, REPRESENTATIVE NORMAN,
WHY STATE FIRST?
WHY BLINKEN?
WHY WOULD ACCOUNTABILITY START
THERE?
>> HIS SECRETARY OF STATE.
HE TOOK AN OATH TO PROTECT THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HE FAILED IN EVERY RESPECT.
THE PROBLEM HE IS, THERE'S A
TIMELINE OF EVENTS THAT TOOK
PLACE STARTING WITH BIDEN
STARTING GIVING DATES, STARTING
WITH THE EMBASSY WAS EVACUATED
3,000 PEOPLE ON APRIL 27th.
MAY 15, HE GOT A MEMO THAT IT
WAS DANGEROUS OVER THERE AND TO
GET AMERICANS OUT.
BAGRAM, JULY 2 WHICH FAILED.
OPENED THE PRISONS UP TO THE
MOST DANGEROUS TERRORISTS WITH
OUR EQUIPMENT.
IT'S JUST BEEN A DISASTER FROM
DAY ONE.
WHAT LOOK MIKE POMPEO DID.
HE GAVE BRIEFINGS AND HE HAD AN
ACTION PLAN.
BLINKEN HAS FAILED.
THAT'S WHY THE DISASTER IS THERE
AND WHETHER BIDEN LISTENS TO HIM
OR NOT, HE SHOULD RESIGN.
THAT'S WHY DR. HARRIS AND I WILL
IMPEACH HIM.
LET'S PUT IT TO A VOTE AND SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Pete: YOU THINK YOU WILL GET
TRACTION OR THIS?
ARE THERE OTHER OFFICIALS YOU
WOULD LOOK FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR AS WELL?
>> FIRST OF ALL, VERY FEW THINGS
THAT WE DO ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS
IN WASHINGTON.
WE ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS AGREE
THIS WAS ENTIRELY BOTCHED, THAT
THIS WITHDRAWAL IS A
CATASTROPHE.
THIS WAS NOT A DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE EFFORT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE WAS
RUNNING THIS WITHDRAWAL.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE PLANS TO
EVACUATE EVERYONE.
THEY ALLOWED THE MILITARY TO
LEAVE BEFORE WE EVACUATED OUR
AMERICANS.
THIS OH THE FIRST AND FOREMOST
FALLS SQUARELY ON THE SECRETARY
WHO HEADED THE DEPARTMENT THAT
WAS IN CHARGE OF THIS
WITHDRAWAL.
>> Pete: GENTLEMEN, THANKS V